[موسيقى]
ممثل ممكن تكونوا شفتوني في حاجات زي ليه
لا ماشي تمام
ب 100 وش انا كمان بلعب بلعب مزيكا بلعب
مونيكا
بس الحقيقه يا جماعه ان انا من ثلاث سنين
ما كنتش هذا الشخص
من ثلاث سنين
شكلي غريب شويه بس انا كنت مهندس
ففي مهندسين كتير النهارده زي ما داش كان
بيقول في ايه ستين في الميه بيشتغلوا اكتر
من بره مجالهم
فالحقيقه الثلاث سنين اللي فاتوا دول
شاهدوا بتاعي
بتاعي من المهندس
للفنان
انا مش جاي عشان احكي لكم بقى قصه سعودي
في عالم الفن ولا قصه نجاحي خالص على
الاطلاق انا جاي احكي
اللي حصل لي والسلف ديسكفري جورني اللي
انا مريت بها
دي الحقيقه هبتديها من الصوره الغريبه دي
ليه
حد حد متخيل ليه
نرجع تاني كده
عشان انا دلوقتي لما ببص على الصوره دي
ببتدي افهم ليه انا كنت شخص داخل هندسه
بمزاجي
جايب مجموع كويس جدا متخرج بتقدير جيد جدا
مع مرتبه الشرف اشتغلت في شركه
كبيره جدا شغلانه اي حد يحلم بيها بابا
مرتب كويس
محبوب شاطر في شغلي واخد اهو ما اعرفش ايه
طب ليه ليه اصلا اغير كل ده وفعلا لما ببص
في الصوره دي بحاول اعرف
ما حدش برضو قادر يعرف ليه
ايه بقى مالها عيني بقى
حزين
حزين يا جماعه انا كنت حزين انا كنت تعيس
انا كنت فعلا مش مبسوط في الشغلانه دي انا
كنت حاسس ان انا مش متحقق على الاطلاق
حاسس انا مش
في الفيلد مش جاي لي اي احساس بالاشباع من
الشغلانه دي وكنت حاسس كمان اني ما عنديش
طموح ببص على مديري ومدير مديري ومش شايف
ان انا عايز ابقى في المكان ده
طب عايز ابقى فين وما عنديش اي موتيفيش
بصحى من النوم الصبح مفيش حاجه مفيش اي
درايف بيوديني للشغل
وعلى سيره بقى الماتيفيشن عشان الموتيفيشن
كلمه قالت كثير في في السبيك بتاعه زياد
كذا حد جاب سيره الموتيفايشن كانوا
بيعلمونا حاجه بقى وقت
وقت لايف انه عشان بقى في ونشجعهم على
الشغل انه الاساليب بقى القديمه بتاعه انه
ادي للموظف فلوس فهيشتغل اكتر الحاجات دي
ما بقتش ما بقتش نافعه قوي او يمكن تبقى
ناجحه لو الوظائف
وظيفه بسيطه وظيفه فيها جهد بدني هتدي
للعامل فلوس هيدي لك
انما كل ما الوظيفه بقت كومبليكيت اكتر
وبقى فيها جزء
والحقيقه الدراسه دي اتعملت في في ام اي
تي كان فيها
وطبقت بيزنس كتيره جدا وكانت ناجحه
واكتشفوا انه اللي بيموتيفايت الناس في
الوظائف دي هما
ايه بقى الكلام الكبير ده
هو ان الواحد يبقى عنده الحريه ان هو
يشتغل في الحاجه اللي هو عايزها في الوقت
اللي هو عايزه مع الناس اللي هو عايزهم
ويطلع اللي نفسه فيه
هو الاتقان انك تبقى عايز تعمل الحاجه دي
كويس قوي وعايز تتقنها وعايز تتطور فيها
وتتحسن فيها وكانوا بيدوا اكزامبل على ده
انه بيلاقوا ان الموظفين بيرجعوا بعد
الشغل مهدودين ويقعدوا ساعتين يلعبوا
جيتار طب يا جماعه حد اداهم فلوس عشان
يلعبوا قطار لا ده هم بيدفعوا علشان
يتعلموا وياخدوا كورسز بس لقوا انه الدافع
ورا ده هو الاتقان هم عايزين هم سامعين
الحاجه بتتلعب وعايزين يلعبوها بنفس
الجوده عايزين يتقنوا الشيء ده
ودي كلمه كبيره قوي بقى ان الواحد يحس
بقيمه اللي هو بيعمله ده يلاقي مردود عليه
مردود نفسي يحس ان هو بياثر في الناس حاجه
حاجه تحسسك بالفلفله فعلا
ومنها ده في البيزنس حاجه زي الاوبن سورس
في مهندسين كتير وناس عباقره في المجال
بتاعهم بيعملوا بشكل فالنتير
بيشتغلوا وبيبذلوا مجهود عشان يطوروا زي
اللينكس والاباتشي من غير ما ياخدوا فلوس
عشان يساعدوا الناس عشان يحسوا ان الناس
استفادت من شغلهم فدي من اكبر التطبيقات
في البيزنس
وانا على قد ما كان عندي قدر من القطانه
مي والماستري في الشغل بتاعي ودائما بدور
على وانا رايح على الشغل بس فعلا كنت
برليت اكتر للراجل اللي بيلعب جيتار ده
وبتحس ان كل حاجه في المجال بتاع الارز هي
اللي بتموتيفتني فعلا انا قادر اخد جيتار
اقفل على نفسي الاوضه واطلع اغنيه
قدر عايز عايز اتعلم اكتر عايز اطور اكتر
في المجال اللي انا فيه ده بتاع الفن
وطبعا في الفن يعني
ممكن باغنيه
انتم اتهيصوا اغير المود بتاع حد تعمل عمل
درامي فتاثر في المجتمع اتغير طريقه
تفكيره
كان اقوى بكتير في مجال الفن وحسيت انه طب
ما هو ده
وانا اولادي كنت شغال كنت بامثل من ايام
الجامعه وبلعب مزيكا وبعملها جنب الشغل
كهوايه
وما فكرتش خالص ان الموضوع ده يبقى الكبير
بتاعي بس لقيت انه طالما الفيلم بتاعتي
جايه من الموضوع ده طب
انا عايز فعلا اجرب
مش عايز اندم على ان انا ما جربتش مش عايز
مش عايز اقول طب انا فاشل ولا ناجح في ده
انا عايز اجرب نفسي وفعلا قلت خلاص
بس هعمل بقى الكلام ده ازاي
شايفين النظره الى المستقبل
الموضوع ما حصلش في يوم وليله يعني ما
قمتش فجاه ودخلت على مديري وقلت له بص انا
انا هستقيل الموضوع كان اعقد بكتير وخد خد
خد يمكن اكتر من سنه سنتين بفكر ازاي هعمل
الخطوه دي لان انا هسيب كارير ستيبل جدا
واخش على حاجه انا مش عارفها
وفي عينان شيلي الموضوع
مش عارف فعلا انا هبقى ناجح فيه ولا لا
فقعدت اخطط الموضوع ده وخليت الموضوع يبقى
كالكوليتد لان هو ريسك كبير انا داخل عليه
واول حاجه قلت هعملها هو ان انا هوسع
الفاونديشن بتاعتي في الكارير الجديد اللي
انا رايح له ده هحاول اسعى فيه بشكل جد
اكتر
اخذ ورش بشكل اكثر ازود دائره معارفي اعمل
الحاجه اللي كنا بنسميها في الهندسه الميك
بيفور بريك ابتدي اشبط في الشغلانه دي قبل
بسيب الشغلانه اللي قبلها وسيفب احوش عشان
انا مش عايز ابقى معتمد ماديا على حاجه
انا لسه مش عارفها مش عايز ده يسبب لي
احباط وقرر ان انا فاشل
ومعيش فلوس فارجع وما اديش التجربه حقها
وقلت هاسيب اللي يكفيني سنتين هدي التجربه
دي سنتين اشوف فيهم ايه اللي ممكن يحصل
وفعلا في 12 سبتمبر 2019 انا فاكر البوست
ده عملته على على فيسبوك وقلت يا جماعه
انا سبت الشغل وتفرغت للفن
وحطيته كده يعني ما دخلتش دي اول مره اخذ
منه سناب شات وارجع ابص عليه
والحقيقه ان الموضوع ما كانش سهل خالص
وانا مش داخل بقى دلوقتي علشان اخوض في
تفاصيل قصه الكفاح بتاعه التمثيل ان قصه
كفاح فعلا موضوع محتاج طول الوقت مليان
احباطات في داونز كثير
وفي بقى
الميتافيسيو فوبيا الا وهي عنوان التوب
بتاعي
هي الخوف من التغيير الخوف من الانون اللي
احنا رايحينه ده وده طبعا كانت حاجه بتشل
الناس انها تتحرك فكل العوامل دي كانت فوق
دماغي
ومش عارف اعمل ايه
وكثير بقى في اللحظات بتاعه الداونز بفكر
في
معنى كنت قاعد
يا باشا بيجي لي مرتب على يعني اخر الشهر
وزي الفل انا انا بفكر كمان ان انا قعدت
خمس سنين في هندسه 12 سنه بشتغل في المجال
بتاع
فين ده كل ده راح في في الهواء بس الحقيقه
انه لا لا ما كانش انا فعلا ما ندمتش لان
كل الوقت اللي انا قضيته في ده
لمده 17 سنه في حياتي انا جنيت العائد
بتاعه الردي انا
الاكسبيرينس دي خلتني واقف على رجلي خلتني
قادر اصلا احوش عشان اغير الكارير ده
الاكسبينس دي بنتني جرو تشيبني علمتني
علمتني حاجات كتيره في البروفيشنال لايف
وعلمتني اصلا بتاعه
الكارير شيفت دي
ببص بقى دلوقتي يقول هل انا سعيد
الحقيقه ان انا مبسوط جدا وراضي الحمد لله
لاني على الاقل بصحى كل يوم وبعمل الحاجه
اللي انا بحبها
ميرسي جدا شكرا ودي ودي حاجه بجد لو
تعلمون يعني الفلوس ما تشتريهاش
حاسس لاول مره ان انا عندي
حاسس ان انا
بعمل فعلا حاجه
اللي انا زي ما كان دكتور بيقول مين عنده
قدرات في ايه انا حاسس ان دي الحاجه اللي
انا اقدر ادي فيها وعندي فعلا فيها طموح
قادر يبقى عندي
وقت مع اهلي اكتر ادي وقت مع صحابي اكتر
العب رياضه
ده كرافس ده عصير كرافس اللي انا بشربه ده
طعمه وحش قوي بس هو هلس جدا انصحكم تشربوه
ملعب رياضه انزل اسوق عاجل
وطول الوقت بسال نفسي هل انا سعيد
طبعا انا شكلي سعيد قوي في الصوره دي بس
ده مش حالي على طول بس انا برجع للسؤال
بتاع هل انا سعيد لان هو ده السؤال اللي
اصلا الرحله دي كلها
العيون اللي كانت بتدمع في الصوره
الاولانيه
وانا شايف ان السؤال ده مهم نساله طول
الوقت لنفسنا في حياتنا لانه احنا بنتغير
طول الوقت والحياه حوالينا بتتغير
والديزايرز بتاعتنا بتتغير واحتياجاتنا
بتتغير فطبيعي طبيعي انه نبقى عايزين
حاجات مختلفه طب هي اللي كان بيساعدنا في
وقت مش بالضروره هيبقى بيسعدنا دلوقتي فمش
عيب خالص اوكي توريه اساس
نقف ونقول وانا وانا تمام انا مبسوط اللي
انا بعمله ده هل انا عايز اغير طب ايه
دوافع ان انا اغير طب هغير ازاي
ده شغال على طول احنا طول الوقت بنتعلم عن
نفسنا بنفهم نفسنا اكتر كل سنه بنعرف
نفسنا اكتر فعلا فدي دي دي ما بتوقفش ما
تخافوش من التغيير كونكر
هي حاجه بتشلنا بس ده طبيعي ده ده الطبيعه
الانسانيه بنخاف من التغيير بس لو حسبناها
كويس وفكرنا ايه الدوافع مره التغيير ده
وحاسسنا الحسابات مش بالورقه والقلم بس
فعلا انت لو مرتاح في حاجه ده ده ده يعني
مؤشر قوي جدا
يا جماعه انا مش بحاول اعمل توك على
شكرا شكرا مش بقول لكم تمردوا على لايف
استقيلوا من وظائفكم ما بقولش كده خالص
انا بقول الثوره بتاعكم حاولوا تفهموه
اكتر ما تخافوش من التغيير
الماتش شكرا شكرا